alle die sich ein bisschen für norwegen
interessieren und leute die ohnehin
gutes gedächtnis haben die wissen
natürlich sofort um was es geht
das größte attentat der norwegischen
geschichte eine der schlimmsten
geschichten überhaupt der jüngeren
terroranschläge und das ist jetzt in
einem spielfilm umgesetzt wurden
du wirst doch nicht so spiel
das beeindruckendste ist ganz klar die
hauptdarstellerin eine junge
schauspielerin aus norwegen andrea
bernzen heißt wie du wirst das nie
verstehen
die spielt das unglaublich die hat eine
große ruhe im spiel und gleichzeitig
merkt man hier die völlige
verunsicherung ganz großartig so okay
denn die wussten ja nicht was da
passiert das war nicht jemand da
hingekommen ist irgendeine große
verkündigung gemacht hat jetzt bringe
ich euch alle um aus den und den gründen
sondern fing einfach an zu schießen
ja aber deswegen ist ist es ja wichtig
dass wir hier sind und dieses absolute
gefühl der unsicherheit des
ausgeliefertseins auf einer insel von
dem man ja auch einfach nicht wegkommt
das versucht dieser film genau in der
zeit abzubilden die damals das attentat
auch dauerte ja mama das verstehe ich
aber wir sind hier auf einer insel
das ist der sicherste ort der welt
entspann dich kein grund zu machen
der mann hatte mehr als 70 minuten zeit
auf die verschiedenen menschen dort zu
schießen und genauso lange verfolgt auch
dieser film das geschehen er macht es
ungeschnitten das heißt er erzählt in
gewisser weise in echtzeit
die sehe ich jetzt gerade nicht aber
haben sie schon begrüßen ich mache das
gern baut erst mal noch mehrere figuren
auf und genau wie es natürlich damals
auch gewesen ist trennen die sich gegen
verschiedene verstecke
selbstverständlich werden auch einige
getötet die im film vorkommen und man
bank und wimmert wirklich die ganzen
mehr als 70 minuten die dieser angriff
dauert mit dieser figur und hat
tatsächlich das gefühl man ist mit
diesem so schwierig sich zu nehmen
ganz spannend dass nachher davon rede
ich nicht und das problem des films ist
sogar dass er manchmal so unglaublich
gut gemacht ist dass man so ein bisschen
anfängt als filmliebhaber zugucken naja
passiert das dann geht das wirklich ohne
schnitt zu arma den erst ein lich wer
den film ansehen sollte das sind alle
zuschauer die sich dafür interessieren
die eine solche psychologischen
ausnahmesituation abläuft soweit man das
überhaupt rekonstruieren kann ich hoffe
sehr dass niemand von uns jemals in so
eine situation kommen wird man lernt
auch nichts für diese situation
sorry dass ich spaß hatte ich dachte
dass wegen entschuldige hast du nicht
mitgekriegt was passiert ist ich war
emilia die mutter von oder arbeitet im
regierungsviertel
das weiß ich noch nicht schwächen muss
man bei dem film ganz klar sagen ist die
absolute perfektion der macht ist schon
ein film der in jeder sekunde sehr genau
weiß was er will
also keiner von uns weiß eben was
spekulieren bringt da auch nicht
außerdem ist ja auch nicht für alles
verantwortlich
er spricht nur aus was alle denken das
sind die momente wo man eben aus der
handlung wirklich herausgerissen wird wo
man sich ein bisschen verliert in der
bewunderung für die technische
perfektion
während der film eigentlich nur
anteilnahme erzeugen möchte und
hineindenken in dieses schreckliche
diese schreckliche situation und da hat
erik poppe als regisseur sein ziel
vermutlich doch verfehlt aber wirklich
mal vorgeführt zu bekommen was ein
terroranschlag bedeutet für die menschen
die damit konfrontiert sind die völlige
hilflosigkeit das ist etwas was ich viel
eindrucksvoller finde als all die
verschiedenen horror thriller und
sonstigen dinge die bei uns künstlich
angst erzeugen
dieser film erzeugt leider gottes
künstlich keine angst diese angst vor
einem konkret da und er versucht sie so
betreut wie möglich abzubilden und
dadurch ist ein viel viel schlimmerer
film als all die horrorfilme aber
natürlich auch ein viel faszinierend
und den einwand kann ich nachvollziehen
das ist die große schwäche des films das
jetzt zu perfekt man gebannt ist